Transcriber: Sundos Hammoud
المدقّق: Ghalia Turki
لِمَ تبكِ؟
أنت رجل ومن المعيب أن تبكي.
يا ابنتي لا تضيعي وقتك بالدراسة،
في النهاية مكانك الوحيد هو بيت زوجك.
هل ترى أبناء عمك الناجحين؟
لماذا لا تكون مثلهم؟
يا لحظّك التعيس يا ابنتي!
لقد تزوّجت جميع البنات في عائلتنا،
أما أنت فستبلغين الـ 25 من عمرك
ولم تتزوجي بعد.
لم تحصل على معدلٍ عالٍ
في الثانوية العامة؟!
إذًا، سيرافقك الفشل طيلة حياتك.
من المستحيل أن تحصلي على هذه الترقية،
فأنتِ امرأة وستنشغلين بعائلتك وتفشلين.
من منّا لم يسمع هذه العبارات؟
بالطبع ستقولون لقد سمعناها كثيرًا.
المشكلة التي نواجهها هي
أنه من لحظة ولادتنا يضع المجتمع
بجانب ثيابنا قوالب جاهزة حسب أهوائه،
ويحاولون حشرنا فيه رغمًا عنا،
حتى نكون نسخة من النسخ
التي لم تُضِف إلى الحياة شيئًا.
منذ لحظة قدومك للحياة
يحدِّدون كل ما يخصك،
حتى أنهم يختارون لك
ما يجب أن تكون عليه في مستقبلك.
ويُلغون هويتك المميزة،
التي من أكبر الدلائل عليها
هي بصمتك التي لا يمكن أن تتشابه مع أحد
حتى وإن كان أخوك التوأم.
وتمضي الأيام ونكبر.
وتغزو هذه الأفكار تفكيرنا،
ونضيع في ضجيج الحياة،
ولا نعرف ما نريد بالضبط.
ولكن الإنسان الذي
يرى نورًا في مرآتِه،
يساعده ليرى حقيقته المميزة،
أنه مختلف،
وأنه سيضيف للكون شيئًا
لا أحد سواه قادرٌ على إضافته،
هو إنسانٌ محظوظ.
وبالمناسبة،
أصبح المحظوظون كُثر مؤخرًا
لأن شعلة النور هذه أصبحت
موجودة في كل مكان، وعلى كل مرآة
لتجعلنا نرى الإنسان العظيم
الذي يوجد بداخلنا.
التغيير شرارة شغف،
تُشعل أحلامًا وأهدافًا
لا حدود لها ولا نهاية
وغالبًا، لن يرى هذه الشرارة أحدٌ سواك.
لحظة..
لحظة واحدة فقط كفيلة بنقل
حياتك من الجنة إلى النار،
أو من النار إلى الجنة.
وهذا التغيير يبدأ منك أنت،
عندما تتذكر عبارة مهمة جدًا بحق نفسك
"وتحسب أنك جرمٌ صغيرٌ
وفيك انطوى العالم الأكبر".
بالمناسبة، أنا فتاة أكره التسوق،
والبقاء في المحلات لمدة طويلة،
وأكره حفلات الأعراس جدًا،
وغالبًا عندما أضطر للذهاب إلى السوق
أو حفلة عرس يكون شكلي هكذا..
منذ أن كنت طفلة صغيرة
أكره أن يقلدني الناس،
لأنني أحب أن أكون مميزة.
وعندما كبرت كان قلبي مغلقًا،
ولم أكن أرى إلا الظلام.
ونسيت "غالية" الصغيرة ماذا كانت تريد،
إلى أن جاء أحد الأيام حيث
قررت فيه أن أقول كفى للعتمة،
وحتى تمكنت من الخروج من العتمة إلى النور،
تطلب هذا سنين من عمري،
وتعبًا وجهدًا وتفكيرًا.
حتى أنني في بعض الأحيان كنت أفكر
لماذا يهمني هذا الموضوع؟
لماذا أريد أن أكون "أنا"؟
ولماذا أريد أن أكون مختلفة عن الناس؟
إلى أن جاء اليوم الذي
خرجت فيه من هذا الكهف،
الكهف الذي حبست نفسي فيه،
وكنت محرومة من رؤية العالم خارجه.
عندما خرجت منه ورأيت
العالم الجميل في الخارج،
تمنيت لو أن بإمكان الجميع
أن يرى النور كما أراه أنا،
وقررت أن يكون دوري
في الحياة أن أمكّنهم من رؤيته.
مهما كلفني هذا الأمر من تعب،
وكلام محبط من الناس واستهزاء منهم.
وهكذا كانت شرارة التغيير لدي
عبارة عن منشورات أكتبها
يوميًا على الفيسبوك.
ولكن الحلم الذي في داخلي كان أكبر،
"رح نعيشها غير، بس على طريقتنا"
هي عبارة عن كلمات كنت أكتبها
صباحًا قبل أن أتوجه إلى عملي،
وأبدأ يومي بها مع أصدقائي على الفيسبوك.
عندما بدأت في الكتابة،
كنت أعتقد أن أصدقائي
سيرونه كأي منشور آخر،
سيضغطون زر الإعجاب وهذا كل ما في الأمر.
ولكن اكتشفت بعد فترة، أنني أؤثر
بأشخاص أعرفهم وأشخاص لا أعرفهم.
وذلك عندما بدأت تصلني رسائل من الناس،
كلمات صادقة تعبر لي عن مدى تأثرهم الكبير،
وأن شيئًا ما تغير فيهم بسببي.
"غالية، لقد أعدت إليّ الأمل"
"غالية، أنتِ السبب في
عودتي إلى الحياة من جديد،
عندما أقرأ منشوراتك
تعود إلي الهمة والأمل."
لم أكن أتخيل أنني سأكون قادرة
على التأثير بحياة أحدهم بتلك الطريقة.
الشعور بأنك قادر على
الأخذ بيد أحدهم إلى النور
بدون أي جهد، وإنما مجرد
كلمات عفوية نابعة من قلبك،
تكتبها عن شعورٍ ما في داخلك،
أو تجربة مررت بها،
أو عن شيء حدث معك.
هذه اللحظة كانت بداية لطريق لم أكن
أعرف أنه مقدّر لي أن أمشي فيه،
ولكنني لم أكن أراه.
"رح نعيشها غير بس على طريقتنا"
بدأت منذ أكثر من سنة ولا زالت مستمرة.
ولأنني لا أريد للأمل أن يكون مجرد كلام،
ولأن التغيير بحاجة إلى فعل كبير ليتحقق،
سألت نفسي: "غالية، ما هو أكثر
شيء مهم توافره
حتى نستطيع القيام بشيء مهم في الحياة؟"
وكان العلم هو الجواب.
إذا استمررنا بالتأمل والتفاؤل دون
القيام بشيء سنقتل الأمل بأيدينا.
ولكن عندما نحول الأمل إلى عمل،
نكون بذلك صانعين للتغيير.
وآمنت في أعماقي أن هناك
العديد من الناس القادرين
على صنع المعجزات،
ولكنهم بحاجة لشرارة البداية،
بحاجة لمن يآمن بهم ويدعمهم.
ومن هنا نشأت فكرة Magma.
Magma هي التغيير،
وهي القدرات العظيمة المختبئة في داخل
كل واحد منا والتي تنتظر بركان إرادة لتخرج.
لقد كان مجرد حلم حلمت به،
وكان في البداية مجرد رسائل قصيرة
تحمل داخلها عالم من الأمل
والحلم وإرادة للحياة.
وُلد من رحم إيماني بأنني
لم أخلق عبثًا، وبأن لوجودي غاية.
هذا الحلم لم يبدأ بمعجزة، ولكن إيماني
بأن مشوار الألف ميل يبدأ بخطوة
جعلني آخذ هذه الخطوة وأمشي بخطوات
ثابتة وواثقة ومليئة بالأمل والشغف.
وقودي في طريقي،
هو إيماني بأن الله معي
في كل خطوة قد مشيتها
وسوف أمشيها وفي طريقي كله.
وأنا متأكدة أنه مهما كان التغيير صغيرًا،
سيأتي يوم أغير فيه شيئًا ما في العالم.
يقول "ستيف جوبز":
"المجانين هم فقط من يعتقدون
بأنهم قادرون على تغيير العالم،
وهم فقط من يغيرونه."
ولكنني سأقول لكم:
كونوا مجانين بما يكفي لتفكروا
أنكم تستطيعون تغيير العالم،
وعاقلين بما يكفي لتغييره فعلًا.
لم نخلق لننجرف مع التيار،
بل لنكون نحن التيار،
ونحن التغيير، ونحن الحياة.
شكرًا.
(تصفيق)